hey you guys and happy Valentine's Day
we decided that well I decided that
since this is the movie retrospective
that is going up on actual Valentine's
Day
unless you're a patron in which case
you'll say that the day before and
because shudder just added this slasher
classic to its lineup
I decided of course we should do My
Bloody Valentine from 1981 yeah yeah we
should have done Friday the 13th because
we had a Friday the 13th this year
didn't we it was in December or January
yeah oh well we thought into things
we're just trying to get the show done
yeah that's true it's like I'm just kind
of like well I was kind of planning on
doing this one anyway and then I was
like oh shut her out of it I was like
her and I'll have to rent it I mean when
you do the research for a show you do
the research for [ __ ] sometimes two
or three days depending on what the
topic is I mean some of the movies are a
little bit easier because then you can
just watch it sometimes I watch it twice
and then I'll usually like read through
[ __ ] on it watch documentaries about it
like watch other people's reviews of it
stuff like that sometimes depending on
what it is but yeah so my buddy
Valentine which came out in 1981 this is
a Canadian slasher flick and I feel like
it's kind of it doesn't get brought up a
lot when you're talking about sort of
classic slashers or you know kind of big
ones in the genre which is kind of a
shame because this one I always really
dug this one I think this is the first
slasher movie I saw as a kid that made
like a really big impression on me
and so I must have seen it I mean it
came out in 81 so I don't I didn't see
it in the theater so I must have seen it
on cable which means I was probably 10
when I saw it first
yeah um and it scared the crap out of me
I don't know why I know like I watch it
now but it's like I've found it really
really scary like the miner the killer
me the pickaxe and everything I found
there it's funny I mean this one really
didn't stick out for me I mean I think
cuz I had seen stuff like maniac and
yeah the Friday the 13th part one I
don't think I saw this at the time that
it came I don't think I saw most of
these flashers at the time that they
came out really I was watching them on
HBO and Cinemax so I never really could
tell which ones were older than the
other ones yeah but
remember seeing this one and not being
all that freaked out by because I'd
already seen some other ones yeah we're
a lot more intense like I said I think I
might have seen some before this but
this was the first one that like scared
me and I and I think it was kind of like
I think it was the the minor and the
pickaxe which you don't see a lot of
slashers that use a pickaxe as a weapon
yeah also you know just that kind of
like the darkness and the claustrophobia
of the mine and stuff like that which I
think was really well utilize I liked
this movie but as a kid I kind of got it
confused or I put it up I guess I got it
kind of got it confused with terror
train and maybe put it on the scene yeah
cuz Terra traitor we met like the year
before this one maybe a year before
yeah right and I like to tear a train
too even though I don't remember terror
train being very graphic yeah I think so
his head got stuck on one of those damn
spikes you put papers on yeah yeah yeah
I remember and maybe sometimes that
lettuce in there too I miss all this is
kind of like Friday the 13th on a damn
train yeah except in when you find and I
remember that when you find out who was
doing it you're not too impressed but I
still like the movie yeah that's a great
movie we should actually probably review
that one yeah haven't seen at some point
but yeah so my Bloody Valentine came out
like I said in 1981 this is a Canadian
movie now the guy that directed it he
was actually I think he had done kind of
a teen comedy type of thing called
pickup summer and that was like pretty
successful so he got offered a to
picture deal and they wanted him to do a
slasher now the original screenplay was
actually just called the secret but
since there had been like you know
nothing to do with that [ __ ] New Age
or whatever but it's like that movie
that the secret had be gone for a little
bit it had a lot of people going it I
said oh yeah you know your water you
know your mind can affect the water it's
like you know you're happy vibrations
know it really good dinner snap me out
of it you're like wait hold on think
about what you're saying
yeah yeah you're right yeah well you
know I had a background in [ __ ] seeing
paranormal [ __ ] so I thought maybe yeah
maybe that might work but that
particular way of describing things no
that's that's a that's a philosophy
like I said it has a very dark side to
because the the flipside to oh if you
wish for something hard enough you'll
get it yeah everybody that gets [ __ ] on
in life it's because you you wished for
beds you wish for bad sober you brought
her alongside victim-blaming that's what
I mean so that's kind of another reason
why but anyway so the original script is
called the secret but because there had
been such a success with slasher movies
based around holidays obviously Black
Christmas Halloween stuff like that and
I think even this year
81 maybe happy birthday to me I think
that came out as well
yeah April Fool's Day you just reminded
me a happy birthday to me too I remember
liking it Melissa Sue Anderson from
Little House on the Prairie at it I
can't I can't remember anything about it
but as soon as you said that title I
remembered why you don't remember this
the shish kebab skewer yep in the mouth
yes if you like the most iconic gotta
see it again I just watched it again
like it well that was probably like
three or four years ago all right I
remember like yes it's pretty good
actually like I said I remembered that
the biggest thing making an impression
other than the shish kebab thing was
Melissa Sue Anderson being in it because
that's the only other thing I'd seen her
in besides little house that Bram like
Mary no you know what I mean because I
was kind of really haven't seen that
haven't seen this one again this was a
lot better than I remembered it the
quality that was a lot better and now
that I'm thinking about terror train
yeah I haven't seen those things in
forever
terror train was probably pretty shitty
compared to this one I remember liking
territory and then I was I was thinking
of the quality of the production though
yeah I think I have to see it again like
I used to think Friday 13th was it the
3d one was good yeah until I got it
watched it again I was like man he's
like this oof just just wanted to are
good yeah that's it well I'm like I said
Friday the 13th to which is also sort of
a holiday themed slasher so so the
producer was like or the director was
like okay well what holidays haven't
they done yet so let's do Valentine's
Day
yeah now this was a Canadian production
and it actually ended up costing about
2.5 million dollars to make they shot it
in Nova Scotia in a real abandoned mine
so that's that kind of like it's funny
because they have like these two
locations right like these two mines
that we're gonna use they were both
closed like the one that they ended up
you
had closed in 1975 so we want the one
that they decided to use in this little
bitty town in Nova Scotia the people in
the town were so excited that they were
going to shoot a movie there that they
went into the mine and cleaned it all up
and they were like well we didn't want
it all clean if we wanted it all yucky
because they had to go back in there it
spent all this money to like [ __ ] it up
again yeah you guys know like [ __ ] yeah
it was perfect the way it was but yeah
so as you can imagine filming in a
real-life mine this mind is 2700 feet in
underground so all of these actors they
said the shoot was like [ __ ] horrible
because they really had to like go up
and down like in this book and they were
really down in there and you know they
had to worry about all the same [ __ ]
that miners have to worry about like
methane gas and like [ __ ] that you
know they had all the equipment they had
you can only have so many light bulbs
going because you didn't want any spark
sorcerous everything I got a handle the
movie is that yeah it did kind of have a
good ambience is because it was filmed
on locations yeah you know and they
didn't spend any money for that location
that was a good idea to do that they got
a decent location for nothing and I
wonder why they don't do it because I
mean they they film a lot of horror
movies in like abandoned warehouses and
[ __ ] like that
they don't utilize mines very much and I
wonder why because mines had a good dish
darkness that gets but yeah but I mean I
know it sucks for these people but like
the movie came out pretty good because
of it also another thing that kind of
sets this one apart from a lot of other
slashers is that the victim pool are
older they're not high school kids
they're not teenagers they're like older
they're like working you're still young
but they're working on us and this is
set in a very working-class you know
community it is odd which think of us
you don't really see much I mean most of
you look people like Halloween Friday
the 13th stuff like that they usually
like middle-class Motel kids or college
kids yeah those adults that's good one
too there's another one but like I said
you don't see a lot of ones like set in
sort of a working-class community like
this not many there's there's really not
that many
so the basic form is on the other
there you go but in in a way this kind
of like has a little bit I don't want to
say it's exactly the same because the
fogs more of a classic goes story and
this is more like a straight-up slasher
but in that sense of you know just that
kind of small town is working-class
community it really does have this much
as as much as Carpenter was it was like
disappointed with the fog that made a
big impression on me as a kid yeah me
too I love that movie I thought it was
super great the adults at the time
weren't too impressed with it but
because it wasn't scary enough but it
was enough for a kid yeah but we weren't
paying for the tickets true so what you
tainted mom we weren't the attendant
audience well yeah but when you're
[ __ ] 10 or 11 12 see the fog is like
oh man well yeah it was crazy you never
really saw it very much
you know just he's [ __ ] down I
thought they were pirates because I
wasn't really grasping the story right
they were like pirates more like lepers
yeah lepers in the ship yeah but the
thing so okay so the the kind of
backstory about this is like it said in
the in a fictional town they shot it in
a real town but it's a fictional town
called Valentine Bluffs and apparently
20 years ago in the mine where everybody
works in this town there was a big
Valentine's dance because that's kind of
the whole this town's whole thing is
Valentine's Day so they have this dance
and apparently a couple of the
supervisors had gone to it like they had
gone off their shift early like to go to
this dance and they had neglected to
check the methane levels in the mine
before they left it was an explosion and
six miners were trapped in the mine now
five of the miners ended up dying and
the sixth one Harry warden actually was
stuck down there for six weeks I think
they said and ended up having to eat the
other miners to stay alive and by the
time they found him he was bonkers so
they let him out they got him out of the
mine and then he went and murdered the
two people that the two supervisors that
had been responsible for the explosion
and then they put him in a a mental
institution
so this has happened 20 years before the
you know the events of My Bloody
Valentine now they have not had a
Valentine dance in 20 years in this town
because Harry warden warned
everybody if you guys have another big
Valentine's Day dance or another
celebration I'm gonna come back and kill
all you [ __ ] so they haven't
done it but finally they're like look
it's 20 years it's like everyone's
probably [ __ ] forgotten about that by
now like all the people that work in the
mine now are young people they don't
even remember it because it was before
they were born so they're planning to
have a big ass Valentine's Day dance
however a couple of days before
Valentine's Day people start getting
little heart-shaped candy boxes big old
bloody human humor art cinema suicide
which that was something that really
made a big impression like that like
when the cop like gets the box and he
reads the card and it sounds like kind
of a little rhyme in there it's kind of
like hey everybody's gonna die whatever
and then he opens it and I was like oh
yeah and their hearts are much bigger
than a human heart they're like that
they're probably like a [ __ ] B but
it's not well yeah but I mean you I
looked at when I was a kid I was like
man I'm going yum Thank You universe and
I see secret admirer yeah Americans
don't know about heart hearts good man
chicken heart - [ __ ] he loves chicken I
love gr yeah I think you talked about
that before on the show still did that
to me going to South Korea Bangladesh
Oscar II need them to have whole swords
full dontcha with chicken are ya guys
just coming pulling that putting that on
your plate they eat like dozen of them
at a time I'm just guys how salted
chicken hearts yeah over an open fire
food he's gotten I'm here a couple of
times yeah I don't remember where you
got them but chicks are stupid Oh sue
yeah that's right yeah yeah we got yeah
that's right we have yeah they have a
screw here yeah there's a couple of them
I've never been there good I'll take you
okay they're expensive but it's good I
don't want you got 60 70 bucks I can't
get best yeah chicken hearts any bucks a
person so so people in the towns start
turning up dead most famously Mable who
works at the laundromat or owns the
laundromat I guess she loans the
laundromat she gets killed by this
big-ass miner with a pickaxe who
pickaxes her and then puts her in the
[ __ ] dryer and then the next day they
find her she falls out of the dryer and
she's like all burn [ __ ] nothing like
rolling around and [ __ ] like that so
this the cool thing about this movie -
other than it being set in a
working-class community which
see other than you know the victims
being a little bit older than your
regular slasher victims this also has
kind of an element of whodunit to it
because even though you would think
because you've seen Halloween you would
seen other slashers where it's like oh
the killer did this [ __ ] 20 years ago
and then they were an insane asylum and
then they escaped and came back and
that's what everybody thinks in this
movie - but then the weird but then like
some weird [ __ ] happens where they're
like they called a mental asylum and
they're like look we don't have any like
record of that guy's which means that he
either like got transferred somewhere
else or he died or we don't [ __ ] know
where he already was never here so that
kind of like adds an element of is this
Harry warden who was escaped and he is
coming back and doing it or is it
somebody else because since the killer
is in a miner's outfit and every dude in
the town and some of the women to work
in the mines it could be anybody because
everybody has that outfit and once
people put that outfit on they all kind
of pretty much look like that so so like
I said there's kind of a whodunit
element - and there's also and I'm not
gonna say that like this isn't like a
tease cheesy because it is like all the
characters are very cheesy there's like
a couple of them are sort of over the
top but in a good way though I like it I
like that style and they're actually
most of the characters are actually
pretty likable yeah um you know even the
prankster guy who's kind of annoying is
[ __ ] but it's like you know the fat guys
his whose name is Hollis it's like that
and then they set up like a love
triangle like between like one of the
girls and she has like this one guy
named TJ who was her boyfriend and then
he decided he was gonna go try to make
his fortune elsewhere and he couldn't
make it so he has moved back in the
meantime she has gotten with his bro
like it's not his brother but like his
friend and so there's like a lot of
tension going on there like with three
of them and then finally she's fighting
with them and she doesn't want to be but
like I said the the characterization is
really well done to an extent where you
kind of feel bad when they get picked on
it's not kind of just like please die
you know what I mean like cuz some
slasher movies are kind of like that
that old that old eighty style when done
right was really good because yes it was
theatrical it was comforting each
character kind of
was a part in a little morality tale and
there might be a couple of groups of
people where little morale details are
kind of going if it was done right yeah
it was never supposed to illustrate real
realism yeah it's not it was never
realism not even back in the 80s but I
like it and when it's done right it's
done you still see it every now and then
yeah them do it in a more modern movie
but I think I think the quest for
realism is kind of destroying the the
entertainment factor for a lot of movies
yeah I mean like I said it depends on
how was on its because sometimes like
realism you know will get you more
invested in the story it's gonna con
story it depends on what kind of story
it is yeah I do feel like people will
forgive kind of over-the-top caricature
sort of people like in a slasher movie
because that's kind of one of the tropes
of the genre yeah and I think really
when you're making a slasher movie
mostly people are watching it for the
kills for the tits and entertainment
just for an entertainment type of thing
like cut just you know kind of a scary
cop popcorn movie they're not like right
I love that that tone and that style for
horror yeah for me I think kiss realism
in horror doesn't it for the most part
doesn't it's not effective on me it's
not as entertaining I know I just I
don't know if it was maybe growing up
watching you know from beyond and
reanimate her and Evil Dead you know
those movies were never had a serious
tone they were supposed to they were
just fun to watch yes and in a way the
only thing that the only tone that I
thought maybe had a little bit of
realism that was I thought was affect it
was like the first time I saw it be like
Friday the 13th or yeah Halloween yeah
that's about as real as you want to go
and and if you look at the little scenes
for the teenagers before they got killed
there's not a lot of realism there
either yeah they weren't like that even
back then no and like I said I think
that's the situation here as well you
have certain character archetypes that
aren't really like real people but in a
way they're like cinematic real people
yeah you know what I mean it's kind of
characters right it's like a stock
character all right um but like I said I
think they did a really good job like
kind of establishing
you know kind of all the relationships
between everybody another good thing
that I like is that in this movie they
did they pulled kind of a jaws where
there's kind of a thing where once mabel
turns up in the dryer
the mayor basically says okay well we're
cancelling the Valentine's dance he
doesn't [ __ ] around like he should see
he's like look whether this is Harry
warden or whether it's a copycat
somebody is warning us not to do the
Valentine's dance so we're not gonna do
it so it wasn't kind of a thing where
you know you know with the [ __ ]
sheriff Brody's like we have to close
the beaches and the mayor's like no
we're not gonna do that it's I mean the
mayor said yes we're not having the
Valentine's Day Day dance but the killer
ends up killing everybody anyway because
all the young people are so pissed off
that the Valentine's dance is not going
on that they said we'll just have our
own party yeah and then [ __ ] goes on
from there and they all get killed from
there now one thing that's very
interesting about this is that it's
funny because I was watching the version
that's on shudder and I'm pretty sure
that the version that's on shudder is
the one is the theatrical cut which
means that there are several several
gore scenes that have been cut out of it
because when I was watching it I'm
sitting there going this is not as gory
as I remember it being like some of you
see some of the kills but like they
seemed like truncated so so what I was
researching this okay so what happened
with this movie when it first came out
this is really dumb because the studio I
think it was paramount they had asked
for a slasher movie and they gave them
two and a half million dollars and they
said because you know Friday the 13th
had been such a big success and
everything like that so they said well
we want to do a slasher movie so they
gave him the money to do it and then
when he produced the final movie they
cut out now he says it was nine minutes
which is a lot they said well you have
to cut nine minutes out of this or it's
gonna get an X rating and obviously no
horror movie wants to do that because
then a lot of newspapers won't advertise
that a lot of theaters won't show it I
mean specially back in those days ya
never know aftermarket back then right
so and there wasn't a lot you could do
miss theatrical release was like a big
deal so you pretty much had to take it
in the butt like if you wanted an R rate
so he says they took out nine minutes I
don't know if all of it was gore some of
it might have been some other [ __ ]
because they did restore some of the
gore later on it was only about two or
three minutes so I think some of the
other nine minutes he was thinking about
was just like some other character
scenes and [ __ ] they took out wonder if
you can get it you can because what
ended up happening was that when they
decided I think it was in 2009 to do the
remake My Bloody Valentine 3d it was
Lionsgate studios so they got the rights
to My Bloody Valentine and they found
the excised gore footage and not only I
thought this was pretty cool of them so
when they put it out on blu-ray to court
to correspond with the remake coming out
they didn't just throw the deleted gore
scenes into the deleted scenes extras
they actually took the time to edit them
back into the movie where they were
supposed to go now the only thing about
it is that if you watch because I went
on YouTube and somebody has put like
some Russian person has put like all of
the gore scenes that have been cut and
they put them all back in there now you
can tell because the movie was restored
quite beautifully because actually this
does have really nice cinematography for
an 81 slash or maybe surprisingly also
has very very good special effects I
guess a like the practical effects what
I was saying I'm saying it was yeah it
looked a lot better I remembered it it
did yeah so the only thing is that since
the the main movie was restored the when
the gore scenes were put back in where
they were you can tell a little because
they're not quite as good you know the
film quality isn't quite as good because
they had been like stored somewhere for
such a long time right but order to
restore yeah but that's what was so
funny is that I it's just funny that I
thought I was like god I remember that
being so much gory er and when you see
the excised scenes you can kind of see
the what ended up happening I think they
ended up cutting out so much because
they didn't usually cut that much core
out of horror movies especially slasher
movies especially once that they had
asked for for Christ's sake but I think
what ended up happening was one Friday
the 13th had come out the year before
and they kind of got a lot of backlash
about how gory that was which is funny
because it doesn't really seem that gory
to me nowadays but back then it was also
it my Bloody Valentine came out not that
long after John Lennon got
shot and for some reason John Lennon's
death was like such a big like cultural
deal that like a lot of people were kind
of like they don't want violence and
gore and [ __ ] like we're complaining
about it and I remember it yeah so Bob
because the new people in newsmen were
blaming movies you're the increase in
violence right that's not what was
happening so I claimed they were blaming
damn music and yeah and video games the
beginnings of video games yeah here's a
trip I remember a time where there was
no there weren't any video games where a
human being was the target in the damn
video games yeah they did that for a
while except it was like a shoot-out at
OK Corral type game but yeah because I
remember it's funny you could shoot all
the people you wanted to in westerns
yeah but you shoot people in like yeah
back then they did yeah but yeah so you
know no one knows if that's why
Paramount cut so much of it out but when
you see the excised Gore scenes like I
said this practical effects in this are
very good um this is a pretty [ __ ]
gory movie I mean there's scenes where
one guy gets a pickaxe it goes through
his chin and comes out his eye socket
and like a [ __ ] eyeball comes out the
woman in the dryer it they show it a
little bit like in the theatrical cut
but in the extended cut I mean they show
her like she's hanging out like flopping
around like outside and she's like all
[ __ ] burned off and [ __ ] like that
there's one scene at the end where
they're all trying to escape from the
mine and the elevator is broken because
the killer has [ __ ] it all up and so
they have to climb like 2700 [ __ ] feet
like up this [ __ ] ladder and one of
their friends like comes down and he's
like on a rope and the Rope like pulls
his neck taut it pulls his head off and
then like the body falls and flops
everywhere and [ __ ] like that so it's
like there's some really good gore
effects in this but I think you know we
watched it a couple nights ago on
shudder and I was got I was like I feel
like there there's more gore in it than
that and then when I went and they were
like yet there was so I guess the one
that's on shudder is not the extended
cut I guess it's the theatrical cut yeah
I must have seen an extended cut at some
time huh I watched it I watched all the
cut out scenes today I found them all on
YouTube because the
like I said okay so they saw the
original one you just don't like or
something it was missing yeah I guess
not I think because of the editing and
editing right and because I guess I was
hearing chatter from like a lot of
horror
you know websites and stuff like that
that this was like a super gory movie
and then I was said they must have been
talking about the extended cut which I
had never seen no one I watched it with
you is just it was tame I thought yeah
well like I said a lot of the gore has
been cut out right so that's why I put
it up there with terror train which is
another Canadian one and in terror train
I remembered it scared me the first
couple times I saw it as a kid but then
when I realized I didn't have to hide
behind my eyes and look that not a whole
lot was happening yeah and I was under
the impression that Canadian horror
movies were not that gory but see like I
said particularly with horror movies you
really have to do your research if you
see something particularly slasher movie
and you're just like man that was like
the gore and that was really lame you
should go look because a lot of times
[ __ ] got cut out got cut out maybe um
Ennis because um what's-his-name was
Canadian and he made some pretty you
know the guy from Videodrome David
Cronenberg he made some [ __ ] he made
some fucked-up [ __ ] so I don't know I
just remember being a kid under the
impression that Canadian movies weren't
awarenes gory but I might have just
might have been just because of those
two movies as just during that time and
you never know like I said um sometimes
you don't know it's a Canadian movie
dude
or yeah and you and I actually think
when I saw this as a kid I don't think I
realized it was that it was Canadian
even though I mean the way that the
people talk should have yeah what the
hell is this happening and I said I
think I I called it I said I think it's
Nova Scotia it was okay because it
sounded like like somebody caught making
like a bad impersonation of an Irish
accent another funny thing about this
and I saw I saw some other review maybe
it was bloodbath and Beyond I don't know
but they were reviewing this movie and
they said did [ __ ] moose head beer
like pay for this movie because yeah
because pretty much every scene there's
a lot of scenes take place in Happy's
bar and you know they're all drinking
like moose head beer even in the [ __ ]
laundromat scene
like where Mabel finds the [ __ ] you
know finds the candy box before she gets
axed there's like a kid there she has
like a box with Valentine's decorations
that's sinful yeah like that I didn't
really I noticed it a little bit we were
watching it cuz I'm like oh I guess
moose head like paid for some product
placement but when I watched it back
again I was like oh yeah [ __ ] move
said beer they're all over this we had
it in Michigan yes it's a very Canadian
yeah it's just [ __ ] you know just like
anything else I really couldn't tell
from American beer at the time yeah I
don't think Miller I don't think they
sell it down here yeah it's just from
what I remember it's kind of one of
those things now like I said in 2009 I
think they did a remake of this which
was in 3d you guys I have seen the
remake um I remember it being okay like
being not terrible the 3d is actually
pretty well done there were some
practical effects but a lot of it was
CGI which you know there was kind of a
cool scene where cuz [ __ ] Tom Atkins
was in that [ __ ] and there was one scene
where he got the pickaxe through here
but it pulled his jaw off and then the
jaw came right at your face dan also
there was a great scene where one girl
got like the shovel like through the
mouth gag kind of like Tom Savini did
that like back in the 80s but that and
then like her head slides like the top
half of her head like slides for her
like the bottom half of the fault so
that looks pretty cool like in 3d and
everything IRA Michael but honestly I
think the practical effects in the
original one like I said it particularly
in the extended cut I think they just
look a lot better practical effects in
general always look a lot better but you
know this is kind of one of those I feel
like poor Canada they kind of get
forgotten about particularly in the
horror movie slasher movie kind of sight
I mean they made [ __ ] black Christmas
man that's like one of the best one of
the earliest slashers yeah I'd have to
say where I'm gonna put it I'm gonna put
it up there with terror train from what
I remember yeah production values and
quality it's a higher than Friday the
13th one and two it is it's shot much I
shot a lot better that you know I think
the acting is probably better though I
think one and two Friday the 13th had a
bigger impact
hey watching that I think this one
almost has a little bit too much too
much dialogue almost too much story to
it it would have been better to dumbed
it down and just see that I mean yes I
mean it comes out I think um I watched
killcount there's a there's a really
funny channel called killcount where he
like talks about the movies and says how
many people died in and how they died 16
people get killed in this we just it
just seems like there's a lot of
dialogue for what it is yeah it was just
kind of wordy and I was like like
they're having scenes to have a scene
yeah but you kind of felt like but you
know what it's not it's not a bad move
it's good movie yeah I definitely think
it's it's one of the better slash yeah
it's a it's a good it's high-quality and
I and I'm really here's one thing that
amazed me one I'm amazed that more
horror movies don't use Valentine's Day
as a thing because bread hearts come on
now um you know love unrequited whatever
revenge that type of stuff also I'm
really sad that the minor killer didn't
get a franchise which is really weird
because that I mean the minor getup
it's like he kind of breathes like Darth
Vader cuz he's got the breath thing it's
like he's got a [ __ ] pickaxe man yeah
he was cool he wasn't deformed though
trail if he was deformed like Jason
Voorhees or something it would have it
would have been more American it had
been American his [ __ ] trail he should
have been burned up or had something
really wrong with him so he could take
that mask off and he would just look
like a monster yeah that's what I mean
the end of this I don't necessarily want
cuz I said it's it's kind of like a
whodunit I know it's 1981 but I know
probably a lot of people haven't seen it
so I'm not gonna spoil like who the
killer had actually ended up being but
they left it open at the end where if
they had wanted to do a sequel they
could have it would have been like
pretty easy to do um but for some reason
they just never did and it's weird
because it seemed like a lot of movies
that did worse than this or had less of
a cult following than this got a whole
franchise and this one never got one it
got a remake but that's it Friday 13th
and Halloween was a lot cheaper and it
was kick kicking and kicking this movies
ass I guess so I mean her teeth just
sold lots of tickets yeah
I mean this one made more than twice its
budget back but it didn't make a pretty
good it didn't make as much as Friday
the 13th so I guess they just figured
man whatever the overheads Canada even
though I don't know I don't know what it
cost them to make this two and a half
million how much did it cost to make it
Friday 13th oh you know what I don't
know I don't know yes probably try half
that because I mean this one I feel like
since they shot it in a real non-working
mind I would imagine that the insurance
and like all the safety equipment and
all the [ __ ] like that data do probably
ate up quite a bit what made the
American slasher work was that you know
you could just take some unknown actors
and actresses not paying much and for a
million bucks make make it basically
kind of just like an entertaining
piece-of-shit movie they you could make
a bunch of profit at the box office and
then it would go on to Cinemax or yeah
HBO why do you think is I mean forever
why do you think there were so many of
these yeah and then later would actually
you could do a lot of VHS action from
[ __ ] Bach busters yeah they made a
lot of money over time with a very small
investment and that was that was the
beauty of slasher in horror movies yeah
I mean particularly the slasher movies I
think nowadays like well maybe not
nowadays but you know a few years ago
probably the equivalent feel like a
zombie movie because you can make them
for very cheap and you know but back in
the 80s we were like we didn't have the
internet we were just like starved for
entertainment and people that loved
horror movies you just went to the video
so you saw every [ __ ] one because
it's like what the hell else and you'd
see them from and you'd see them
multiple times yeah this isn't something
you know kids today or whatever people
today they're not watching movie I'm
saying it can turn - god damn it right
in my day well lots of things over there
phones right there almost got to be
immune to imagery because they're
bombarded with imagery constantly and
lots of information and pretty good
quality information compared to what we
used to have yeah so movies like this
aren't very you know if they watch it
once again well we were almost
brainwashed with him well yeah cuz like
I said we did watch a 30 or 40 times cuz
they just read run out well I said I
don't want to watch I don't want to
watch that I'm gonna put Friday 13th in
- again
oh yeah a [ __ ] run I was just gonna say
I mean I taped Friday the 13th part to
off Cinemax or HBO or whatever
I must don't watch that [ __ ] thang
400 [ __ ] yeah because it's just every
few weeks that fright night as well yeah
that's every few weeks you'd be like
let's watch that again
yeah you watch it back it up okay now
frame by frame you watch some of the
season I did that's a different shot you
know I mean that's a dummy you know that
kind of stuff oh you try to like yeah
yeah picking apart the specialist
watching a frame-by-frame and [ __ ] see I
never wanted to do that I was well after
you burned it out so much true as like
what you seen a four-footed 30 times you
might as well just slow it down let's
see that again yeah slow motion but yeah
seriously if you're into slasher movies
and you somehow didn't get around to
seeing this one cuz like I said this was
a little bit of a forgotten gem and I
thought that well because shudder just
added it happily even though I was
planning on doing it anyway I said oh
[ __ ] man this is kinda out of
Valentine's Day we got to do my Bloody
Valentine and especially because that
[ __ ] killer would fit the one scene
where the old guy has set up the [ __ ]
fake Meinhard that like is supposed to
like the pickaxe goes like that like
when you open the door like he has on a
string and the one scene where he just
keeps to open it and he keeps it he's
like oh man that's so funny and then he
opens it and the real guy is there and
then like puts the pickaxe up through
the [ __ ] in his face and everything
oh that's good the crap out of me like I
was really little when I saw that and
then like I stayed awake all night
thinking that like a pick axe wielding
miner was gonna come out of it so it's
like yeah so this is um I wouldn't
recommend it to anybody that isn't into
like 80s slasher movies but if you were
into eighties slasher movies and
especially like holiday themed ones then
you really need to like I said that's
why everyone's a thing there was such a
thing I think there's like I I could say
although I could think of like a lot of
[ __ ] holidays that they didn't every
single one of them was [ __ ] named
after some kind of damn day it was it
was it was a [ __ ] trope it was
burning itself out yeah well this was an
early example of it I mean there had
been obviously there's been Friday the
13th or been Halloween there have been
Black Christmas yeah there have been a
couple of other like Christmas themed
ones but
I think I'm pretty sure this was the
first Valentine's that's why that's why
I wanted to go down the HPL it's not a
holiday yeah not a holiday and it's HP
Lovecraft and we didn't even know we
didn't really know who HP Lovecraft was
at the time you know we were like man
where's he live you know we got a guitar
just laughing at like you and your
little friends like going on HP lovers
that [ __ ] live from California
knocking on the door we just saw your
leader well it wasn't like you could go
online and find out who HP Lovecraft was
that's you would never think to ask your
librarian I did cuz I was a nerd yeah we
not ask you be like she wouldn't know
that's questions you know back in the
old days used to call the library and
you can the librarian would look it up
for you cuz I picked out a few times
yeah I guess you could yeah you could
like the librarian we're looking at for
your holy crap or so that was [ __ ] smart
people did yeah I think it's um I didn't
I did that kind of show all right I just
go to the library go just stay in the
dark is actually my friend Jason Quinlan
finally could Franta showed up with HP
Lovecraft books yeah and explained it to
us
alright he did he was like he would tell
us what it was what it what it was about
we didn't really want it like we didn't
want to read it tell us what it was
about
we didn't time that [ __ ] nerd oh yeah
yeah we would just marvel over what he
told us I ended up reading in the
mountains of badness yeah and there's a
couple other ones that I read Dunwich or
yeah and I don't know there was I don't
think I saw him not color out of space
one with the damn aliens well that could
be a lot of them yeah yeah I'll never
remember it you know what's really weird
what am i every to take him back to the
planet they came from the head to take
him in a jar
oh yeah oh [ __ ] man we saw the HP
Lovecraft society like did oh yeah fill
me that yeah cuz it was one of the
better stories only read the good
stories yeah some of those are a little
small stories they're good but for some
reason I really dug pickman's model I
don't know why that one just made like a
really big impression on me when I
I don't know but yeah so like I said if
you're into holiday slashers from the
80s you really need to check this one
out because I feel like a lot of people
probably haven't seen it
remake is okay too but I would actually
recommend the original over it just
because the practical effects are better
even though the remake is totally fine
also we need to do April Fool's Day one
of these days because I'm really good
new tear train and will do terror train
yeah I need to write all this [ __ ] down
but yeah so anyway check it out it's on
shudder like I said it's not the
extended cut it's the theatrical cut so
keep in mind that there's a lot more
gore that you're missing out on so go to
youtube and find those scenes if you
really want to see it and happy
Valentine's Day we will see you next
time bye